[Music]
hello and welcome it is World Press
Freedom Day and we're devoting this
episode of quadriga
to assessing how well journalists the
world over are able to do their job
which of course is nothing less than
telling the truth and let me start out
by saying the news isn't good right here
at DW our colleagues are calling
attention to rising repression they're
posting images of the Turkish publicists
and brothers Ahmed and magnet Alton of
the Chinese editor Dingley GA of the
Saudi blogger Ralf Badawi names and
faces that stand for hundreds more
journalists worldwide who face detention
and torture for critical reporting and
putting the light of the notion that
Europe is an island of press freedom
journalists are being murdered here as
well so that is deeply disturbing of
course to all of us who work in the
media business but what does it mean to
you dear viewers in the age of social
media and citizen journalists as a free
press really matter journalists under
fire who cares that's our topic here on
quadriga
here our guests it's a pleasure to
welcome aunty Bauer she is a freelance
journalist in her work training for the
DW Academy she travels to regions like
the Middle East she says not only are
journalists being killed truth is killed
in times of alternative facts what
remains our attitudes and prejudices and
we're very pleased to have with us on
the show Vladimir is it well he has
worked in Russia for the axil Schwinger
publishing group and is now based in
Germany working for DWS russian language
programming
he says the Ettore authoritarian states
do not really need to kill journalists
they have much more sophisticated
instruments to bring the media under
their control and finally it is a
pleasure to welcome Shi Ming he is a
freelance journalist born and raised in
Beijing he left China in the late 1980s
worked in Germany since then and she
says the boundaries between journalists
and non journalists are blurring which
makes it more difficult to protect press
freedom so a warm welcome to all of you
the World Press Freedom Index published
last week by the organization reporters
without borders reflects what it calls a
worldwide to decline characterized by
quote hatred of journalism so I'd like
to start out by asking all three of you
to reflect a little bit on your own
experience and whether you would say it
corroborates that finding a finding of
rising hatred of journalism are you
seeing that in the form of threats or
other risks to telling the truth are you
remembering a quote of a Russian press
minister a couple of years ago maybe
2014 and he said it's a good thing to
get as much journalism jobless
journalists jobless as possible because
it will be rised the competition among
monitor journalism so that was the goal
of the Russian state at the time to get
as much journalism out of their job and
it's obviously part of the decline of
the press freedom in Russia
anti power your work in Europe of course
as well but particularly I know that you
travel to the Middle East you train
Middle Eastern journalism would you say
they are facing that kind of rising
animosity yes I think there are they are
squeezed between two walls of animosity
one is the animosity by governments as
long as they do their job as they should
do it and on the other hand is mistrust
by the people who don't share their
ideas they think that journalists too
who write things which don't which are
not in agreement with their own opinions
are biased so they have this double
problem one hand the authorities which
are against them and and rise in
mistrust from the people for whom they
work in the end
thank you very much a phenomenon of
course that we've seen in the US with
the rise of polarization and we'll come
back to that in just a moment and for
you seeming when you look especially at
China would you say that you see this
active hostility toward journalism that
the the president Freedom Index is
reporting no I think it is a very
complex on the one hand the me Trust is
increasing but not just against
journalists but against the media in
general because all of the media are the
control of the state that the state
spends everything else and most people
most Chinese are not relying on this
media law if they switch to social media
where they don't know who is really
journalist who is internalist
and they sometimes mistrust somebody but
they don't say we just mistrust
journalists they do mistrusted because
they don't know who is that behind some
news some assessments some judgments and
opinions they just don't know so
reporters without borders the
organization that puts out the Press
Freedom Index they also say
quote/unquote hatred of journalism is
actively threatening democracies all of
you are now based here in a democracy
you will live and work in Europe would
you say that that is true or is it
perhaps a bit hyped I think that the
Russian assault on the press freedom in
Russia it's a part of the broader
assault on the democracy on itself
because press freedom or freedom speech
is a crucial part of the globalization
and we are facing the assault on
globalization itself because it's not
only about freedom of speech it's about
freedom of elections about democracy in
general so obviously yes power yes I
think it's it's the question is what
does it mean freedom of speech freedom
of speech means that people are allowed
to know what's going on in the moment
that freedom of speech is threatened
doesn't work anymore people see only a
very small part of reality a part which
is being wished for by those who who
prevent them from speaking out and so
that means that people can decide
anymore on on what they want because
they are manipulated while we're
deciding on a very small piece of
information getting via Twitter and then
things like the American elections
happening because people are free in the
country with the free press like us but
the result is very interesting
essentially a shaming it's a question of
whether we see journalism and the media
as an active part of a democratic system
is it you know sometimes we have like to
call ourselves the Fourth Estate a
pillar of democracy do you think that is
still the case in the eyes of people
beyond the media themselves oh yes oh
yes we can split the journalists we're
into in three categories first
information second assessment and third
discussion so the information if you
don't get the information you wish to
have you are very upset you you you you
get a feeling that some someone is going
to happen but you don't know what is
going to happen so some incidents in
environmental context some war some
conflicts and so on so you just don't
have the information so people who
spread this information whether they are
journalist or not
I will come in general but are also
mistrusted whether they're spreading
real information second is assessment
not everyone is able to assess a
situation to assess information they are
receiving so and the third is discussion
whether you could invite people to
attending some discussion and in all
three terms the journalist a journalism
is a crucial part I don't say it is the
only
but it is very very crucial the does not
replace anything else but they generate
they vitalized
all three categories then I think every
democracy is depending on there's three
pillars of interaction among people
without it it wouldn't work I think that
many of us here in Europe would take an
active Free Press for granted
would say well it can't happen here but
the fact is interestingly enough the the
Press Freedom Index of Reporters Without
Borders says that it is in Europe itself
where the decline in press freedom has
been worst let's take a look at two
particularly notorious cases Malta
October 2017 a car bomb killed Maltese
journalist Daphne Cara Juana Galicia her
investigative reporting had uncovered
several cases of corruption in the
Mediterranean country despite massive
protests her murder remains unsolved but
other journalists are continuing her
investigations Slovakia in late February
investigative journalist Yan Coetzee act
and his partner Martina Kirchner ovah
were murdered Kodiak had reported on
organized crime by Slovakia and
politicians protests here at least
resulted in the resignation of prime
minister robert fico
murders of journalists right in Europe
extreme cases of the threat to press
freedom in Western democracies according
to reporters without borders the press
is coming under increasing pressure in
Eastern European countries such as
Poland Hungary and the Czech Republic is
Europe becoming a crisis zone for
journalists
and let me put that question to Antibes
our and that's by the way not our
formulation could in fact the
formulation of reporters without borders
which refers to a continent in crisis
again hype or reality would you say
looking at Europe I think in Europe
there's a very negative development and
a very dangerous development towards
intimidation of of journalists towards
annihilation of independent media by
several means by economic means by
political means and I think this goes
together with very worrying political
developments that is what we said before
that it's goes hand-in-hand we have in
several countries we have a very clear
tendency to autocratic regimes where the
regime on one end is trying to limit
individual freedom citizens freedom
freedoms more and more and the
limitation of Free Press as a part of it
that I'm a sip of repression and
persecution of journalists are often
seen as being associated with war with
autocracy but I was struck by the
connection in those two cases that we
just saw with corruption both of the
reporters who were murdered were
investigating forms of corruption and in
fact state capture tell us something
about that Nexus and is that also part
of the phenomenon we seen in Russia
no Russian government have other
instruments to control the press it's
not about killing journalism in general
it's just the nexus between corruption
and repression of the press the nexus
between corruption and repression of the
press of course every every particular
regime seen danger in the critical press
especially in countries which no strong
tradition of the critical press like
Germany's or
Eastern Europe or Russia is very very
aggressive towards critical journalism
so they're trying to silence them by all
means and trying to put them out of
business is having it with active
Springer in Russia a couple of years ago
then the new Russian law was forbidding
the foreign investment and the media
business or actually springing other
foreign companies were pushed out of
Russia very soft by very soft means or
no repression itself but they were
pushed to solve to solve this business -
the Russian partners so it's a kind of
state control control over their media
landscape she mean would you also say
that having had experience with other
systems at other countries that Europe
has a real problem here or would you say
actually this does still remain an
island of press freedom in comparison no
Europe cannot state out of this general
trends we see also some psychological
effect of journalism which was
criticized very critically by the
economy if this journalism in Europe in
Germany is dealing critically with China
the economy say oh please don't report
that negatively because we need that
it's just business
so it works it works upon the politics
it works upon journalists it works upon
universities we now see the influencing
affect efforts from the Chinese
government through the media through the
university through the journals so I
think it is illusion to regard any part
of the world as island of freedom of
press and so on the globalization has
reached every corner in every terms also
in terms of the press freedom but it can
also be the other case in the other
direction
I just told this this is not a joke this
is the reality for a few days
a Chinese social media blogger has
discovered one picture just one picture
this picture was spread by by state
media and he checked this picture
through the PM beyond China's boundary
and he thought he found out that this
picture spread by a chinese state media
was fake and he posted another picture
to prove that and that that triggers a
wave of discussion on Chinese social
media and discredit chinese state media
so that the spokeman of Chinese defense
minister has to appear for the press and
say I'm sorry it's just a fake this case
shows that we should not only talk about
the negative influences upon this very
wide spreading journalism done by almost
everyone we should also see the hope
that they could be representatives II
that the Chinese regime is now cracking
down on social media as well absolutely
tightening its grip like social media I
simply don't believe that they can
because within the government there are
so many conflicting interests every
ministry ministry wish to bring their
information their truth they utterly
conflicts it with the other ministry
every party organization in the one
provinces conflict the other party
organization part of the journalism on
Chinese social media was founded was
supported but just this conflicting
parties within the ruling party within
the government we are living in a world
where you can might you might be able to
shut down all the media but you cannot
shut down all the interests but of
course what you can do and what we have
seen
done as you just described it but we
have certainly seen it elsewhere as well
is set up a concept of alternative
truths that discredits the truth itself
I checked the Trump Twitter archive this
morning and discovered that Trump has
tweeted about fake news no less than 194
times since he won the election he has
referred to reporters as enemies of the
people
is this just Trump being Trump or is he
in fact absolutely undermining
a free press let's take a look go ahead
go go ahead go ahead no not you not you
your organization's terrible your
organization's terrible let's go
go ahead quiet quiet go ahead she's
she's asking a question don't be rude
don't be rude don't be rude no I'm not
gonna give you a quote I'm not gonna
give you a question
you are fake news go ahead go ahead
[Applause]
Antep I couldn't you say okay it's just
Trump being Trump being rude to critics
has a long-standing tradition amongst
politicians and he's simply doing it his
own way yeah he's doing it his own way
and political political politicians
always have been lying that's normal but
he is he's an a new model in this he
does it much more and he is not only
himself on Twitter yes his old stuff we
remember his speaker who talked about
alternate effects that means somehow he
states an example for something being
more and more spread and more and more
recognized so we have alternative facts
that means we have our narrative it's
not about truth anymore it's the
question how do I present reality and
this reality is as true as your reality
even if they conflict that means that
you completely take the roots of what
should be facts it becomes everything
becomes opinion and conviction and this
is new and this I I see it as a very
very dangerous development coming back
to what you said that the the limit or
the distinction between professional
journalism and citizen journalism is
being blurring blurred more and more
that means everybody can create
so-called truth what's happening in
Russia you don't need to suppress the
real press you don't need to suppress or
to suppress journalism you creating a
completely new reality with fake new
survey with alternative news with
creation of completely new new reality
via social media so the people that
don't trust to classical TV or classical
press anymore they're switching to a
complete new reality and staying there
we saw that happen didn't we with the
script all attacks where suddenly the
Russian government had about eight
different possible explanations
that all contradicted each other but the
point was precisely to set up that kind
of assess system of alternative truth
service so it's very very good during
the crisis in the Ukraine 2013 and 2014
as the news popped up in the Western
media as well which were not real news
but the fake news founded by the Russian
propaganda machine coming back to the
second part of our title we asked who
cares shimming fact checkers continually
disproved not only president Trump's
claims but those of Vladimir Putin and
those of other strongmen and yet it
seems like that doesn't generate all
that much outrage no I wouldn't say that
I think the outreach are being
differently channelled for example if
you observe Chinese a social media
almost every statement of States made
media was questioned almost every so if
you Genesis state may dare say our
economy is running well some of the
social media says no no no no no that
this figure that that figure you don't
know whether the figure feed the the
reality but you know that people
disapprove and even President Xi Jinping
his very mighty figure and he is
compared with we need the pool and all
the Chinese media was shut down whoever
dared to posting a Winnie the Pooh
picture but the Winnie the Pooh are
spreading all over the Chinese social
media in every shape so I don't think
that people don't generally take care of
what really is important to them to
their daily life how they are feeling
whether someone is a this is going to to
kill them or to to do some harms to them
they they care quite a lot but they
don't care in in the form we are used to
know so some of the the classic
journalists
put too much attention to the classic
newspapers that to their televisions and
so on and now it is the difficulty to
figure out how important the social
media and the other alternative forms I
don't say they are correct how important
they are becoming for mattering the real
mood in within the country under power
how would you assess the role of social
media in a country like Germany some
people here feel that there is a
stronger basis of trust in political
institutions and in journalism than
there would be in a country like the US
for example on the other hand we have
the far right using social media to
spread the notion of a lugan presa a
lying press so it can cut both ways
can't it yes I think that in Germany the
the trust in classical media is is
bigger and in other parts then in
dictatorships for example like the one
you said or Iran Egypt people will not
trust the classical medium because they
consider rightly so that they are not
depicting reality I think the question
is how you use social media the question
is like you already said that you don't
know very often who is saying what's on
social media you don't really know the
author you don't need really know is it
right what they say or not whose
interests are they representing so I
think that's the problem
but if we which are not I think
classical media have to transform
themselves and go on social media in
order to remain visible coming back just
very briefly to our title we're almost
out of time but Vladimir in the face of
journalism under fire what can we all do
not only the press but what can others
do we need to wake up to the new reality
to new technological reality into
[ __ ] that with the iPhone everyone is a
publisher everyone is a journalism envy
to push more effort into the new social
media so we have to fight the fights of
the enemies of the press freedom with
their own means thank you very much
thanks to all of you for being with us
and thanks to you out there for tuning
in see you soon
[Music]
you